in italy the trade was done with
pieces the scissors easy to tell when
it was the hair stood up it burned the
point burning the tips the hat
evolves and closing it becomes big it
becomes stronger it doesn't fall anymore
many people because caught because
barbers don't  they know how to cut hair and
burn the ends this is very
important
here we are at the sica barbershop with the
first barbershop in milan and the traditional barbershop
like a farmer sarah had land a
jump knows the fabric once they
did their hair these many
important and i do and  hairdresser
since I was
nine years old now that I'm 82 it's 73
years that I'm a barber
once the barber was a very important thing
now it's very different the barber
no longer exists
I've lived a different world after a
job you have to do it well
do it well  it means to be good
you have hair
don't get cut badly